y volvió finalmente nuestra querida
sección de salud con la responsable más
romeros a la que antes también estaba
haciendo el análisis de muchas cosas que
ocurrían en esta guerra pero por
supuesto no queríamos dejar a un lado la
salud que tiene que ver también con esta
guerra porque hay denuncias varios
ataques contra hospitales en ucrania mar
que sabemos sobre esto si hablamos de
salud pero lastimosamente seguimos sin
alejarnos mucho del conflicto abierto
actualmente en ucrania uno de los
ataques que ha dado la vuelta al mundo
es el de mariupol no con el hospital al
ataque materno-infantil que por cierto y
supimos que una de las mujeres que
salían en las fotografías transportar
una camilla embarazada falleció igual
que su bebé pero no ha sido el único
ataque a instituciones sanitarias o
hospitales que ha habido en ucrania en
total la organización mundial de la
salud ya ha verificado 31 ataques contra
sanitarios o infraestructura sanitaria
hasta el fecha del 11 de marzo entre
estos ataques además se cuentan 12
muertos y 34 heridos dos de ellos raúl
son trabajadores sanitarios qué tristeza
amar qué consecuencias tiene todos estos
ataques y la guerra sobre la salud mar
pues principalmente la salud es un
derecho universal y una guerra es una
interrupción brutal y violenta contra
este derecho además también estamos
hablando de falta de suministros por
ejemplo oxígeno anestesias describir
desfibriladores perdón insulina
todo esto normalmente estamos
acostumbrados a contar heridos ya contar
muertos pero hay enfermos crónicos gente
mayor niños y niñas mujeres embarazadas
todas estas estarán en mayor riesgo a
raíz de este conflicto de ese de hecho
se calcula que van a haber 80.000
nacimientos en los próximos tres meses
que se van a dar unas condiciones de
absoluto riesgo si la situación no
mejora pero también hay consecuencias a
medio y a largo plazo por ejemplo el
comité en ucrania no ha desaparecido y
es importante recordar que es el país
con una tasa de vacunación más baja de
toda europa un 36 por ciento debido a la
reticencia que hay hacia las vacunas una
reticencia que también llevó a que
rebrotar a la poliomielitis en 2020 y
precisamente en este febrero de este
mismo año febrero 2022 se había lanzado
una campaña para recuperar la vacunación
infantil contra la polio una campaña
masiva que ahora se ha tenido que
interrumpir también por esta guerra
impactante es casi que destruir en la
mayoría de sociedades en mar desde la
cndh ucraniano también denuncian que
todos estos ataques son crímenes de
guerra pues así definitivamente los
ataques han levantado muchas críticas
por parte de gobiernos de la sociedad
civil de entidades multilaterales por
ejemplo la organización mundial de la
salud y unicef publicaron un comunicado
conjunto en el que llamaban a proteger
los servicios sanitarios como manera
también de proteger a la población civil
además recordaban pues que estos
servicios sanitarios salvan vidas pero
también sobre la cuestión de si
técnicamente son crímenes de guerra o no
tocará que esto lo dirima una corte de
justicia a la corte penal internacional
pero revisemos la definición de la misma
onu se considera crimen de guerra todos
los ataques intencionados contra varios
edificios entre los cuales hospitales u
otros lugares donde se traten a enfermos
y heridos sin embargo de nuevo para que
esto se pueda considerar un crimen de
guerra y tenga consecuencias debe
demostrarse que ese ataque fue
intencional esa palabra es clave y que
no fuera además el objetivo militar de
hecho rusia haya argumentado que el
ataque contra mariupol contra el
hospital de mariupol también se debía a
que ahí había unas facciones militares
eran su objetivo en verdad pero en ese
sentido si fue intencionado digamos a
ese objetivo porque supuestamente según
moscú ahí estaban nacionalistas
ucranianos así es pero pues sigue
habiendo hasta otro lugar pero ahí como
decíamos la justicia si se decide llevar
al ejército ruso ante la justicia será
quien deberá decir y lo veremos mar
produciendo mil casos de ataques contra
hospitales que vemos en una guerra que
otros casos también se conocen son
múltiples desgraciadamente los ataques
contra instituciones sanitarias se
repiten son una constante en todas las
guerras y en los conflictos por ejemplo
rusia bombardeó hospitales en alepo en
siria donde se calcula que 900
sanitarios han muerto desde 2011 muy
recientemente en 2021 también hubo
bombardeos del ejército israelí sobre
gaza por ejemplo que destruyeron el
único hospital donde se hacían pruebas
cobit y que destruyeron también
instalaciones sanitarias de médicos sin
fronteras pero uno de los casos más
duros que siguen el imaginario colectivo
fue el bombardeo de fuerza aérea de
estado de eeuu contra el hospital de
trauma en kunduz afganistán en 2015 42
víctimas mortales las imágenes que están
viendo son de ese hospital eeuu aseguró
que había sido un error por eso pues
hace falta recordar esa parte de la
intencionalidad del crimen de guerra que
muchas veces juega un papel ahí claro
pero igual siempre digamos que el lado
agresor dice que fue un rumano y allí se
pues se escudan en eso vamos a averiguar
qué pasa y le pregunto entonces máximo
consecuencia sobre ese ataque el que
estaba hablando no hubo consecuencias
penales pero sí hubo una resolución del
consejo de seguridad de la onu apoyada
por 80 miembros donde pues condenaban
esos ataques del personal médico y
pedían el fin de la de la impunidad pero
la verdad es que desde entonces no ha
habido mucho avance no ha habido muchos
cambios según cifras de la cruz roja'
que están viendo en este momento se han
registrado más de 3700 casos de ataques
y obstrucción a los servicios de salud
hasta 2020 dos tercios de ellos en medio
oriente y en el continente africano raúl
cosas que interrumpen algo que se llama
el principio de la neutralidad médica no
que es que se cura y se cuida a todo el
mundo independientemente de su bando y
de sus ideas políticas un remanso de paz
o de colaboración en tiempos de guerra
que deberíamos preservar imágenes de
solidaridad también que hemos visto por
ejemplo de parte de los ucranianos un
vídeo muy famoso dándole comida
digamos bebida caliente a un soldado
ruso y pues como usted también lo dijo
no solamente los heridos de guerra los
muertos por la guerra sino enfermedades
crónicas que deben tratar así que por
ahora está todo paralizado claro y por
eso también recordar que la salud es
vida la vida es el contrario de guerra
preservar la salud es una actitud
pacifista en todo caso una guerra acción
pero es una tragedia mar muchísimas
gracias por toda la información